tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates the
showdown between the u.s. and Iran our
great American forces are prepared for
anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing as president Trump
trades threats with the Iranians what
will it take to keep the crisis from
escalating into a full-out war we're
joined by former White House national
security official Richard Clarke plus a
crisis for American law enforcement
dumper of police suicides it's been a
long and dark year for the NYPD a
sobering start to the new year for the
Chicago Police Department a somber
moment for the Phoenix Police Department
officers under stress after the event I
drank every single day after were
fearful of a stigma they seek help we
have to change the culture that just
because you talk to somebody doesn't
mean that you're weak police officials
desperately seeking answers what the
hell's going on here
and our shoutout for the reporter who
helped to expose a congressman living a
life of luxury with campaign money the
fact is that the case began when Morgan
Cooke published an article in the UT
from the law and crime Network studios
in New York City's Herald Square this is
Brian Ross investigates
and good evening Happy New Year and
welcome a worldwide sigh of relief this
week when it appeared the showdown
between the u.s. and Iran had hit the
pause button after the u.s. targeted and
killed Iran's top General kasam salamati
the retaliation that the Iranians
promised was an attack on two US bases
in Iraq that did little damage and
resulted in no us or Iraqi casualties
president Trump was quick to announce
all is well our great American forces
are prepared for anything
Iran appears to be standing down which
is a good thing for all parties
concerned and a very good thing for the
world to understand this better we're
now joined by Richard Clark who served
in the White House for both Democrats
and Republicans and is now the chairman
of the Middle East Institute mr. Clark
thanks for being here has Iran really
back down to the other side blank here I
think they did I think the United States
and Donald Trump got lucky because they
were dealing with a very professional
and highly calculating Iranian
decision-making apparatus and I think
they made a decision to play for the
long term which is getting the u.s. out
of Iraq and not you know create a
near-term crisis which would have caused
both sides a lot of damage so for better
or worse did this validate the president
Trump's decision to attack the general
take him out
it may have he he was presented Trump
was presented by the Pentagon with a
range of options that he could use to
respond to the increasing pressure being
put on Americans in Iraq by the Kurds
force and by sulemani and Trump went for
the most extreme option presented which
was to kill Soleimani
other presidents have looked at that and
decided that it was too risky
in fact in any normal administration
there would actually be a risk document
that would lay out the risks associated
with each option the option he chose
was highly risky but it worked out and
it worked out in part because the
Iranians thought he was unpredictable
thought he might go extreme again and do
a massive attack on them in response to
anything they did and therefore they
chose to blink and they did this once
before historically they were involved
in the iran-iraq war for eight years and
then the United States by mistake United
States Navy shot down a civilian Iranian
aircraft and the Ayatollah at the time
said oops the United States is coming in
on the side of Iraq which we weren't and
we can't stand up to the United States
militarily right now rather than risk
the revolution rather than risk the
regime will stand down for now
and we'll beat them in the end that kind
of historical lesson is known very well
to the decision-makers in Tehran they
know that happened and I think they
repeated that calculus don't fall for
the bait that will allow the United
States to get involved in the military
operation which would hurt everybody
including the United States back off
back down and regroup and do a long game
where the United States will lose so in
your view the risk of future attacks by
Iran against US forces or military
personnel is now greatly diminished I
would say it's diminished certainly not
greatly diminished the reason they were
attacking us in the first place remains
and that is that the United States has
for the world of hurt on the Iranian
economy so bad that the Iranian people
rose up in November in December in minor
rebellions throughout the country and
somewhere between 600 and 1500 Iranians
were killed and I think at the end of
the day they thought it's too hard to
calculate that with Donald Trump one day
he does nothing
when the Iranians blow up Saudi oil
fields and with drones and missiles and
the next day he goes crazy because one
American contractor got killed in an
attack on the base
they made a rational decision to back
off well Richard Clarke thank you so
much for joining us up next crisis in
American law enforcement
the soaring number of police suicides
more officers take their lives than are
killed in the line of duty on a date
today that was marked by the FBI as
national law enforcement appreciation
day we're going to talk about a crisis
in law enforcement that is only now
beginning to get the attention it
deserves an epidemic of police suicides
across the country it's been a long and
dark year for the NYPD an incessant
drumbeat of despair thanks to an
epidemic of suicide that has spread like
a virus through the nation's biggest
Police Department a sobering start to
the new year for the Chicago Police
Department which saw one of its members
take his life this is the fifth suicide
by a Chicago Police Department officer
in the past six months a somber moment
for the Phoenix Police Department as
today they remember the life of one of
their own former Phoenix officer Craig
tiger took his own life after his family
said he battled PTSD after the event I
drank every single day afterward
every day why self-medicate trying to
race is trying to forget what happened
trying to raise it try to help me sleep
Craig assured us he was okay in
retrospect I'm sure he was just himself
protecting us as we knew today 2019 saw
a record number of deaths by suicide
among the nation's law enforcement
officers 228 former or current officers
took their lives last year that's a 32
percent increase over 2018 police
commissioner's from around the country
say removing the stigma of seeking help
is the first step in combatting this
epidemic the outspoken police union
president Pat Lynch has accused the NYPD
of sidelining officers who do seek
counseling stop destroying the careers
of cops who reach out for help we have
to change the culture that just because
you talk to somebody doesn't mean that
you're weak we have done a woefully
terrible job in providing support to
officers it just almost knocked me down
I just took the wind right out of me I
just know what the hell's going on here
and the department wants all officers
and citizens to know if you or someone
you know needs help please call the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline at
one eight hundred two seven three eight
255 now to gain better understanding
what is behind this epidemic of police
suicides and what is and is not being
done are three people who know a lot
about this in the studio here former New
York City police detective Nick Cassell
who knows a number of officers who've
taken their lives by Skype from
Washington DC is Chuck Wexler the
executive director of the police
executive Research Foundation purse
whose group is out this year on an
important new study on the problem and
by Skype from Massachusetts Karen
Solomon the co-founder of a group called
Blue help and the wife of a police
officer Karen let me start with you if I
can do we really know the actual number
of people and officers who have taken
their lives now we don't we only know
what's been reported to us at Blue help
and this year 228 suicides were reported
to us the number has increased over the
years but we don't really know if it's
because suicides are increasing or if
it's because people are reporting them
to us more often so until this has
tracked nationally
by the FBI so what line of duty deaths
and injuries are tribes we're not really
ever gonna know that number because it's
not mandated reporting a lot of our
information comes to us from the
families but from the news media Chuck
better let me ask you you write in your
report that when an officer is killed in
the line of duty there are big services
we know everything about what happened
there but in a suicide we don't know
that much you talk about the need for
what you call psychological autopsies
right psychological upset autopsies
refer to what what happened what looking
at what were the factors involved and so
much of that information isn't captured
you know researchers have been looking
at this problem for a long time they
have theories it's work-related and
other people say it's it's personal
issues if departments conducted a
psychological autopsy meaning they went
back and they looked at all the factors
and were able to share that information
that would be a tremendous advantage in
preventing it but even we're in 2020 and
we still really can't say why someone
takes their life I think one of the
factors we do know which makes police
officers different is the fact that they
have a firearm and I remember John
Timoney would say you know when a you
know someone has a difficult issue and
they go home and you know they might
have a few drinks and then at night they
go to sleep next day they're fine for a
police officer if he or she has a
firearm that makes it really a difficult
situation so I think what makes this so
hard is we don't know really still in
2020 why officers take their lives and
detective Nick asalaam ask you you've
known a number of officers have taken
their lives how many at least they have
a dozen but there is no common fact
there is it's an abundance of of things
that are going on and I I don't I may
disagree with the fact that the officer
does have a firearm because I mean look
you go to places like Texas Arizona
Vermont where where the gun ownership is
is everywhere so when you look at it
there has to be this combination of
of why these officers doing the
knighting one of the fact is Pat Lynch
of the NYP the PBA really hit upon was
the culture you know no matter how we
look at the police department it's this
macho culture and when you seek help
whether it's through come it's
confidential and not you're still
missing and everybody assumes that
you're going through some sort of
psychological issue and it's it's going
to look bad on you in the present and in
the future when you seek assignment or
promotion I you know of the at least
half a dozen officers that I know never
killed themselves there was no common
nexus all right a question from our
control room from executive producer
Rhonda Schwarz Rhonda Karen at Blue help
you told us you get a lot of phone calls
our family's aware of what's going on or
is this something officers keep hidden
from everyone you know that's really
interesting because some of the families
contact us and they're very surprised
that they're not the only family so when
we introduce them to other families or
we bring them together we have events
for these families we bring them
together they can't believe how many
officers have taken their lives there if
they're actually quite surprised because
it's not something until recently that
has been made really publicly known
through the media
you know 2019 we had excellent media
coverage there's a lot of awareness and
attention to this but prior to that we
didn't know and even now there are
families who don't realize that there
are so many officers taking their own
lives and they don't find us until after
the fact so truly unless they were
looking for it before how would they
know about all these other officers
chuckling so you talk with police
chief's all the time what are they doing
about this issue the stigma of seeking
help well I think I think that's what's
different
I think that's if there's anything
positive in this story is is an
awareness among police chiefs that they
have to speak out about it I just saw
her Edie Rossler from Fairfax County
down in Houston and he was talking about
he was you know has really made this his
issue
Jimmy O'Neil in New York Eddie Johnson
in
Chicago they've recognized that this
issue needs leadership it needs the
person at the top to say look it's okay
to get help and we're not gonna we're
going to make sure that you don't get
stigmatized in some way for this so I
think leadership on this issue is huge
that's what's different this isn't a new
issue I think what's new about this is
that more we're aware of it and I think
the number of officers that take their
lives is greatly under reported so I
think you know leadership really matters
and mr. Wessler is it recognized among
the ranks that this is a real issue
among the rank and file of the officers
oh absolutely - interesting ed Rossler
in Houston said he said there's a duty
to intervene you know we talked about
that in terms of preventing use of force
but in this case duty to intervene
meaning if you see an officer and he's
having a difficult time then there's a
responsibility to help him to get him
help
whether it's an EAP program or a
peer-to-peer program somehow getting
involved listening very carefully and
departments of training of officers what
to listen for how to get help way to go
to get help I think the good news here
is the awareness has never been better
the question is still though what is
pushing this issue and you have a good
sense of that nicka Sal what is pushing
this issue is it the increased assaults
against police complaints of misconduct
I think it's everything there there is
both the pressures seeing the calamity
and horrors during your tour the stigmas
that work the you know pressure from
from the public and the administration's
pressure to always be right I mean it's
a very stressful job being a police
officer and I think that we you know as
Chuck Russell said you know we have to
look at this we have to analyze it but
you know Pat Lynch again with the PBA is
touting more outside the department I
don't agree with the way the former
police commissioner Jimmy O'Neil handled
it
I think that they should be looking for
to help the rank-and-file you have to go
to the people the rank-and-file admire
and respect and that's the unions need
to have a larger part of this all right
well when I hear more about this Nick
Cassell Chuck veksler Karen Salomon
thank you all for being here tonight to
help us understand this very disturbing
trend among America's law enforcement
officers up next our shoutout for the
reporter whose work led to the
resignation this week of a powerful
member of Congress Republican
congressman Duncan Hunter of California
resigned this week from Congress without
offering an explanation of why but as we
first reported last year the why was no
secret to readers of the San Diego
union-tribune
where reporter Morgan Cooke spent more
than a year investigating how the
congressman was breaking the law by
using campaign money as a personal piggy
bank it was a thousand dollars spent on
video games that led to the downfall of
a popular California Republican
congressman congressman Duncan Hunter
blamed his teenage son saying he
mistakenly build some $1,300 to his
campaign instead of using the family's
personal credit card but at the San
Diego Union Tribune reporter Morgan cook
wasn't buying that excuse as she
discovered other questionable
expenditures in the records the
congressman had filed a church for oral
and facial surgery we saw new garage
door there were strange patterns of
charges lots of gas stations lots of
grocery stores just a fast-food a $229
charge at the star trader store at
Disneyland that the congressman claimed
was for food and beverages for the
campaign so I call and I'm like what
kind of food do you guys had and I said
well we have Pez and a Star War themed
rice krispies treat and I was like wow
somebody's gonna have a tummy ache
prosecutors would later document of
$9,200
to Italy for Hunter and his wife
Margaret who also pleaded guilty to a
criminal count along with traveled to
Hawaii resorts in Arizona money spent in
Washington allegedly to pay for a series
of extramarital affairs even $600 in
airfare for the family pet rabbit named
Egbert Cook says she knew almost
immediately she was on to something big
you know we couldn't really let it go
it's like every question we answered
there was another question and another
question and everywhere we looked there
was another question so he couldn't
really let up hunter first elected in
2008 and succeeding his father of the
same name was a well-known and popular
figure in the halls of Congress and as
prosecutors closed in he said he was
being investigated for what were only
accounting mistakes calling it a
witch-hunt aimed at him because he was
an outspoken defender of President Trump
they could try to have a political
agenda as our law enforcement as a US
government I think we've we've seen with
strong and and with the FBI and the DOJ
have been doing let's let them expose
themselves for what they are and that's
a politically motivated group of folks
but late last year the congressman
changed his tune pleading guilty to one
count of conspiracy to convert campaign
funds to personal use likely to face
time in prison when he is sentenced
later this year I failed to monitor and
account for my campaign spending I made
mistakes and that's what today was all
about the federal prosecutor on the case
Phil Halpern said there was nothing
political about it that the
investigation began only after he read
the reporting by Morgan Cooke in the San
Diego union-tribune
the fact is that the case began when
Morgan Cooke published an article in the
UT I read that article I discussed it
with Emily Allen and then mark Conover I
went to the FBI and we said look at this
is there a case and after that we went
we consulted with people in DOJ who in
this administration made the decision
you know to indict representative hunk
hunter nothing
have been more apolitical than the
process that was involved here in fact
today in many ways is a triumph for the
press and shows the importance of having
a free press that not only can the
people rely on but that the Department
of Justice can turn to for guidance Cook
was one of the reporters outside the
courthouse and was stunned to hear what
the prosecutor had to say about her I
think that's what I heard but that
doesn't sound like something that I
would hear very much caught off-guard
because usually and when people call us
out it's not to tell us a great job we
did and how much we helped and how
important we are it Cook became an
overnight journalism sensation her
reporting cited by the networks and
national newspapers a major career break
I think it would take a lot for me to
leave San Diego I think I could still
learn a lot here I can still grow here I
can still do the work that I'm capable
of here and it's a really special
newsroom because everyone is on everyone
else's team and they helped carry me if
I could do it better with help they
contributed their skill and I've just
been really lucky to be in a newsroom
where I have colleagues who support me
and support this work and are willing to
give what they can to to that and that's
our program for tonight thanks for
joining us we'll see you back here next
week